[Music]
talk about taking your breath away
pink and her nine-year-old daughter
willow flew effortlessly through the air
with their duet cover me in sunshine at
the 2021 billboard music awards
[Music]
after this mother-daughter duo's
impressive performance
willow gracefully made her way off stage
as her mom switched into a new look for
her performance of all i know so far
[Applause]
pink then threw it back to some of her
old hits like so what
and just give me a reason
[Applause]
[Music]
the 41 year old is one of only nine
other artists to receive the coveted
icon award
i think there's something to be said for
perseverance i've always told everyone
i'm like a rash i'm not going anywhere
and here i am the honor recognizes
artists who have achieved
excellence on the billboard charts and
have made a lasting mark on the music
industry
thank you this is
ridiculous hi mom hi dad hi jason hi
john bon jovi
while accepting her award from jon bon
jovi pink shared how the musician was a
childhood
crush who broke our heart okay so i have
to tell you
i think you might already know this but
i did not come out of my room for a week
when you married dorothea
i was eight i ripped your poster off my
wall i replaced you with sebastian bach
pink went on to let bon jovi know that
although it hurt
she's glad he found lasting love i take
this as an apology
i accept during her acceptance speech
pink gave props to her daughter willow
for nailing it
and thanked her fans this is an absolute
honor
dream big because what if it comes true
thank you recently pink opened up to e.t
about how she manages motherhood
and being an artist plus her daughter
willow's future career plans
i credit a lot of that to carry because
carrie has his own career but
he pauses every couple of years for us
and
i we are a family unit everywhere we go
we roll together and and i'm
lucky to be able to be the boss and to
call the shots and to
create a universe in which they can
thrive
and i would say my greatest
characteristic is that i attract
beautiful human beings that's like my my
greatest talent
and i have beautiful people around me
and my kids love them and they love my
kids and
they're friends with carrie on we have
girls nights and boys nights he takes
him to a dive bar and we do our moon
ceremonies but
it works i don't know how it works
sometimes it's awful
it's awful it's impossible when the kids
are sick and
or i'm sick or anything it can be awful
too but we just like i said you just
don't stop you keep on going